a true entertainer this was sensational
incredible this is a jaw-dropping moment
get ready to be amazed America's Got
Talent delivered more seriously epic
performances during Tuesday's round of
auditions my name is Maria savage papa
Saba my name is Maxim Papa's off and
we're married couple even though they're
married and have the same balancing act
as their talent interestingly they chose
to compete separately why don't we just
create an act together
it was a nightmare both Maxim and
Maria's skills impressed and both made
it through to the next round my name is
Johnny Manuel I'm 32 years old and I'm
from Flint Michigan Johnny got his big
break at 14 with a record deal and even
opened on tour for in sync but his
career eventually fizzled thankfully his
vocals got him four yeses from the
judges
[Applause]
[Music]
well I am Eduardo
I am Gil and we are your representing
the artist Oscar and gas man -
mysterious visual geniuses opted to
remain anonymous during their audition
which involved projecting different
images onto judge heidi klum the
digitally mind-blowing performance of
course while the crowd my name is
Carolyn Tony's I'm 53 years old and I
Drive a cab in Miami Florida
Carlos proved that you can achieve your
dream at any age stunning the audience
with an operatic number even got a bit
emotional
and sighs I don't have words to say
thank you I'm sorry
[Music]